[Music]
hello Internet welcome to film theory
the show that was cursed by a cult to
kill everyone's childhood one theory at
a time today though we get to strike at
one of fictional history's most prolific
killers no not him again
he couldn't even kill a bunch of hobbits
what oh yeah I guess he did kill a bunch
of people all right so prolific might
not be the right word today we're gonna
take a stab at one of cinema's most
famous killers Michael Myers yeah baby
Michael Michael Myers not Mike Myers
Michael's insane and inconsistent Pass
has been covered in ten Halloween movies
technically there are 11 movies in the
Halloween franchise but Halloween 3 had
nothing to do with serial killers
wearing William Shatner masks so not
really important for consideration today
and yet despite it being the second
longest-running horror franchise of all
time at 40 years no one in that huge
stretch of time has figured out how to
finish off the shape once and for all he
is literally it seemed to be unstoppable
being brought back in film after film
despite whatever damage he took
previously so I got to wondering if I
were a babysitter on Halloween night in
Haddonfield Illinois the primary setting
of the Halloween films what could I do
to not only survive but be the one to
finally stop Michael Myers his reign of
terror once and for all now if you've
never seen Halloween or its army of
sequels then you're probably unfamiliar
with its convoluted story and if you
have seen the movies well then you're
still probably unfamiliar with its
convoluted story since the whole thing
gets retconned every time there's a new
installment basically Halloween is a
bildungsroman a coming-of-age story of a
young man named Michael Myers who in
1963 opens the series by killing his
older sister Judith he spends the next
15 years in mental asylum under the care
of the single worst mental health
professional of all time dr. Loomis
behind that boy's eyes was pelion simply
good medical advice there doc on
Halloween night in 1978 Michael escapes
and goes on a class
Road Trip adventure despite it's worth
pointing out never learning to drive
since again he was locked in an insane
asylum since the age of six
anyway he does all your normal roadtrip
stuff stealing your murdered sisters
gravestone robbing hardware stores for
Halloween masks and teaching young teens
the benefits of abstinence and this kind
remains his MO for the rest of time
occasionally showing up always on
Halloween night to slowly walk from
point A to point B in order to murder
some sexually promiscuous teenagers
long-lost members of his family and the
occasional hermit that keeps ha
stargazing hermit hermit not Kermit he's
not murdering Muppets Halloween six the
curse of michael myers.slc so some
ancient gods a backstory that is
immediately erased just one movie later
in Halloween water wait what
Halloween yeah that's what I said
Halloween h20 Oh Halloween 20 years
later
h20 that's stupid that's a stupid name
and now the new 2018 installment takes
it one step further by erasing literally
everything but the very first Halloween
movie thereby making the only currently
Canon films and franchise to be
Halloween and its new sequel Halloween
so stupid it's so stupid so we know a
story or at least as much as we can know
about his story but if we're gonna beat
him we need to know his power set and
let me tell you what a power said it is
he is slow and he tends to use a knife
when he's presented with something like
a gun he also uses it as just a knife
top tier killer ladies and gentlemen
some people seem to believe that he can
teleport but technically that's not true
because when he's arrested at the end of
Halloween five he needs someone else to
intervene and break him out of jail
other people think that he's a cyborg
because he bleeds yellow in Halloween
six but again that's also not true
because that yellow substance is just a
chemical that had been injected with a
few scenes earlier so what makes this
guy a murderer so threatening that I'm
dedicating an episode to him well to put
it simply he's unstoppable slap
his face on a motivational poster
because he is the embodiment of
persistence we've seen him shot and it
doesn't work
again again again geez guys stop trying
to shoot him it clearly doesn't work he
survives multiple stabbings long Falls
he survives burning with minimal damage
beatings from lead pipes and even Busta
Rhymes can't get the job done when he
tries to crotch shock Michael to death
it is a high voltage wire right to the
groin Oh
likes so we know that shooting stabbing
exploding electrifying and beating
Michael won't kill him but he is human
who see that he eats dogs in the first
Halloween and were able to hear him
breathing throughout the series so when
it comes down to it Michael has two
things going for him super-strength I
mean just look at that one-armed pull-up
and a healing factor that is so strong
that he's able to get his eyes shot out
at the end of Halloween too but then
have him back to full functioning during
the next film so how would you defeat
Michael Myers my first thought was acid
just like cell and Dragon Ball Z you
need to destroy every last particle of a
regenerating creature so nothing can
grow back and with acid it would just
keep burning away no matter how much
Michael regenerated however upon closer
inspection in the series this isn't the
case at the end of the curse of michael
myers.slc
[Music]
doesn't seem to be the way to go then I
thought well maybe the most boring way
possible old age you know it's lame but
cursor no he has clearly shown growing
older and aging starting the series at
age six in 1963 and then 15 years later
proving himself to be a big strapping
adult of age 21 uh uh 23 did no one do
the math here but again this is a no-go
the term death by old age is actually
just a blanket statement for the death
brought about by the failure of an organ
via old dying cells but Michael has
these super healing cells so the organs
technically would never get old enough
to fail and it seems like the movies
know this considering Judith says right
before Michaels carted off to prison
National God will take him to a
maximum-security facility but he'll stay
till the day he dies never die so we
need to attack the healing factor itself
a healing factor that unlike what we see
in Logan shows no real signs of failure
but we also need to remember that cult
or no Michael is at his core human he
was a kid he grows up he's referred to
as a human in the movies he gets knocked
unconscious like every other scene we
see him bleed so he can assume that at
some level his body functions via basic
human biology and basic human biology is
all that we're gonna need to kill him
you see all humans have the biologic
potential to heal regrow and even in
some cases regenerate parts of their
body for instance if your liver gets
injured or you lose part of it or you
donate part of it the rest of it will
grow back on its own back to exactly the
right size for your body so what grants
us our own albeit much slower
regenerative abilities stem cells and
progenitor cells you've probably heard
of stem cells the magic cells that start
off as a blank slate but can evolve into
any type of cell in your body they're
most commonly seen in the growth of
babies before they're born but all of us
walking around have our own adult stem
cells sitting in our body waiting for
their potential to be unlocked now stem
cells have their cousins progenitor
cells which are slightly more specific
than stem cells but can still grow up to
become several different kinds of cell
depending on what kind of progenitor
they are for instance your endothelial
progenitor cells are the ones found
under your skin or near your blood
vessels when you get a cut or scrape
those cells are the ones that are
thought to mobilize in order to heal
that wound and if that kind of special
wound healing ability starts to give you
some ideas well it should because that's
where we come all the way back to our
old pal Michael Myers how we're gonna
finally clump him off for good
this Halloween to do the kind of wound
healing we've seen Michael pull off in
the movies his stem and progenitor cells
have to be running out of control like
sure we can all heal from some bumps and
bruises but Michael is literally
bouncing back from having his eyes shut
out his stem cells are working
over time that makes our job in killing
him really tough because as long as he
has those stem and progenitor cells he
can come back from literally any wound
that we inflict on him theoretically
even something as Extreme as chopping
him in half wouldn't help because with
the work of his stem cells he could just
regrow the missing half of his body and
keep on truckin
no there's only one way to completely
wipe out his healing ability and that's
by getting rid of every single one of
those regenerating stem cells so how the
heck do we do it
one word irradiation specifically total
body irradiation or TBI TBI is a real
medical procedure and it's been used for
over 40 years to help cure very
difficult diseases like leukemia 40
years the exact amount of time that
Michael Myers has been stalking
babysitters in Haddonfield coincidence
yes absolutely in leukemia a patient
produces the wrong kinds of blood cells
those bad blood cells are created by
stem cells deep inside the person's bone
marrow which in case you didn't know is
actually where all your new blood comes
from to treat leukemia one option is to
get rid of all the stem cells in the
patient's bone marrow so that there are
no cells left to produce the bad blood
doctors do this by exposing the patient
to radiation high enough radiation to
literally kill off all the stem cells
existing in the bone if it sounds scary
it is and if you know someone who's
going through this give them tons of
support because it is basically the
bravest thing you can do and yes that
includes facing down a goofy mask to
serial killer now once there without
their stem cells they can't produce any
new blood at all which is why patients
receive a bone marrow transplant in a
bone marrow transplant once the bad bone
marrows been irradiated out new marrow
from a donor is implanted so the patient
has a whole new crop of stem cells
thereby ending the leukemia now in our
case we're not trying to cure Michael
Myers we're trying to get him done but
the principle is the same if we wipe out
michael's stem cells we wipe out his
healing ability thereby making it
possible to kill him without him coming
back but to do that we're gonna need a
lot of radiation a really lethal dose
which would be much higher than what's
used in treatment for even the
system cancers basically we gotta snap
in with everything we've got
now lethal radiation doses are
calculated based on the radiation level
to which exposure would kill 50% of
people within a week a lethal dose then
is technically defined as one gray where
gray is the unit for measuring radiation
to put that in perspective between
flying on airplanes getting the
occasional x-ray and exposing our skin
to the UV rays of the Sun a typical
person is exposed to point zero zero to
four gray of radiation per year's super
high doses for bone marrow transplant
patients range from six to eight gray at
the absolute most but what we need for
Michael is to be so affected by
radiation poisoning that he starts
experiencing symptoms immediately to get
that kind of effect we need a total body
irradiation dose of thirty gray so we
need to crank the dial all the way up
and hit him with the total maximum dose
and it is possible but to do it we have
to be really really smart in order to
expose Michael to radiation we're first
gonna need to lure him into a hospital
easy you simply kite him forgive me for
using a gaming term but kiting is the
process of getting an enemy's attention
and then running away as they chase you
usually well attacking the enemy Michael
Myers is one of the slowest moving
killers in cinematic history so as long
as your car is doing like one mile per
hour you're gonna be fine
maybe think about packing some books on
tape next all that ammo once we've kite
at him into the hospital it's time to
lure him into the radiation ring
hospitals in the US are required to
build in special radiation shielding in
the floors and walls of any rooms that
contain a major radiation producing
machine so as long as he's in and you're
out which let's face it you should be
avoiding sharing a room with that guy in
general you'll avoid radiating yourself
while Michaels busy cooking in his own
personal microwave which obviously leads
the question how do you get a hospital
to let you a babysitter into their
radiation group well the answer is
simple Michael Myers as story is known
in this universe there's even a scene
where people are watching the first
Halloween movie the immortal classic
followed by the big giveaway
it's not just a horror movie over there
it's like a lifetime original feature
based on a true story of heroism and in
the new Halloween movie people are
actively trying to do a podcast with
Michael Myers his story is out there
anyway Laurie Strode at this point has
had 40 years to prep for his eventual
attack plenty of time to get some
doctors or law enforcement or both on
her side they even know what day is
gonna attack spoiler alert it's always
Halloween so if we managed to keep him
in the room at max dose he should start
to show signs of acute radiation
poisoning in minutes including nausea
dizziness and shock and this is exactly
where we want him because now it's time
to go in and finish the job that's right
after all this trouble it's actually not
gonna be the radiation that kills him
remember the whole point of a radiating
Michael was to deplete his stem cells
preventing him from healing himself from
there we use any method available to
shoot out his eyes again inject him with
acid again chopping with an axe or for
goodness sake just decapitate the right
guy this time because now he's reeling
with radiation poisoning and has no way
to heal himself we can finally finally
rid the world of the terror that is
Michael Myers finishing off the
Halloween movies once and for all or at
least until they reboot them in another
10 years but hey that's just a theory a
film theory and guts hey if you want
more horror theories for this Halloween
click the box to the left to see the
true ghost stories behind the conjuring
movies or click the box to the right to
find out why the Blair Witch was the
least of the filmmakers problems when it
came to the Blair Witch Project and
finally make sure you subscribe for more
creepy theories that happen not just on
Halloween but all year round now if
you'll excuse me I need to go answer the
door there's some trick-or-treaters
outside